right there's been an attack in the
capital of Iraq it's reported that a
number of rockets have hit the green
zone in Baghdad that's according to
eyewitnesses and Parliament sources
let's go straight to Mahmoud Abdul wahed
he has more from Baghdad Mahmoud first
of all let me just establish that you
can hear me and the communications are
actually working Mahmoud can you hear us
I can hear you very well all right so
look there's obviously very important
context to these attacks which is that
today Parliament was in session to
attempt to elect yet again a president
of Iraq what can you tell us about the
attacks let's start there at this hour
well first of all according to the media
cell that is a pro-government
information page uh posted that nine
katusha Rockets landed in and around the
heavily fortified green zone injuring a
number of uh
security individuals as well as
civilians that's according to the
security media cell as you know this has
just happened as the parliament is
trying to hold a session today to elect
a new president of the Republic we
understand that some parliamentary
blocks on top of them the block
Affiliated to share influential leaders
today's session and also as you know
that that's not the first time the green
zone is targeted by katyusha Rockets as
the parliament is trying to hold a
session also a week ago when the
parliament was trying to elect the first
Deputy of the speaker of the parliament
to replace that that quitted along with
the sadris lawmakers in June
all right we've lost the sound